in class you talked about escapes for
arm locks and applies here as well uh so
you were teaching arm lock escapes and I
think uh uh choke escapes and and the
question came up but when should an
athlete not tap and risk their arm being
broken and you quoted George Patton as
of course you would uh that no bastard
ever won a war by dying for his country
he wanted by making some other Bastard
die for his country so what's your view
on when to tap and when not not to tap
in competition first off in in training
you should be tapping very early because
um uh you know getting paid to fight in
the gym you're getting paid to fight on
stage so be a professional in the gym
step early tet fast that way you'll
you'll last a lot longer in competition
things were a little different we also
have to specify what is the situation
okay if you're in the first round of
ADCC your first match you get caught
I would always expect my students to tap
because
if you get your leg broken or your arm
broken in the first round you still got
three more matches before you get to the
final there is a Escape Clause there is
if you're a guy from Ireland and you're
fighting the number one seed there is
always an escape Clause yeah like Let It
snap yeah Let It Go but um uh your
students yes yeah I I would expect them
to tap
um I also think that if you're in a
Stranglehold it doesn't make a lot of
sense and not tapping because you're
gonna pass out hey
like it's like you said in cheers it's
kind of impolite to make the guy take it
through to its conclusion so um I don't
see any heroism and and just letting
yourself pass out
um now things change when you get into a
final
if you're in a final and you're hit on
points and
you're willing to
most people at that point are going to
be willing to let something break in
order to win a gold medal
at that point I leave it up to the
student
it's a deeply personal decision I would
never say to a student I expect you to
let your body break in order to to win a
gold medal
um I think my students are more than
mature enough to make up their own minds
uh I would be angry if they let their
bodies break in a meaningless fashion in
some random tournament
or in a first round match where there's
no way you could go on to to the second
third and fourth matches with it with a
broken limb
um but in a final in a gold medal match
in 80cc I would leave the decision to
them a spontaneous decision in the
moment I would be confident that I had
prepared them to do their very best to
defend themselves
um but what ultimately they do is their
decision and
winning ADCC is for a grip or at least
life-changing you're a world champion
forever and no one can ever take that
moment away from you so I would
I would understand if they took a
decision to take damage hopefully it
will never come to that because I do a
good job of Preparing People to get out
of situations as he saw with Gary Turner
who was in a dreadful situation and got
out within five seconds okay so
um uh Gary's been in arm locks that
looked like even I was in the corner
going like oh my God what is happening
here and still got out so uh it comes
down to training preparation but if they
did make that decision I would
understand provided it was a situation
that would make their lives better and
they made a calculation it's not an
emotional thing now sometimes you get
emotional you fight a guy you just don't
like and you just don't want to tap to
them
um
then things get a little more
interesting I then
again it's a personal decision if you
hate someone so much that you literally
can't even conceive of yourself
submitting to them
probably best you don't get into matches
with them in the first place
um but if it should happen
um again it comes down to the student I
teach technique not morals so I let
people make their own decisions on that
my thing is look don't get injured
because if you're injured you can't
train you can't train you can't get
better so stay away from injury as much
as you can